今じゃ初めて像です僕は今まで様々なもの段ボールで作ってきた時にはい希望の作っ
たり時にはメールを作ったりとして時にはローグをつくったりする僕もや深海工具
みたいな乗ったことあるんですけど今ヌーちょっと特殊な香炉ズームジャン
ウホッワッハッハー最低で今回はこちら
ターン食べ物を準備しましたでコザに6色のダンボールを準備しました
あーこのカラー段ボールを使ってそれがチーナダンボールでだシーな鎧を作ってみると
思います美しいオシャレな装備を一式作ろうと思います
いやいや日本海はがちですよピッチャー5種類作る予定ですべぎ戸羽太といろいろ植え
鎧の下あってこの後処理を作っていこうと思いますあの子の薔薇刑なんですけど別を何
も考えずに
作ってるんで最初等をどういうスタートで行こうかなっていうと難しそう
頭の妄想力を膨らませ始め頭の門走力膨らむせ始め
大体の想像はついていきます朝絞めて違ってるかもしれないんで頑張っていきましょう
ジャイ子朝金から作っていろんなボール頑張ってるんでそこでれた倍段ボールを使って
カタチづくりを考えていこうと思います
goo
配給日の無事続きは完成しましたこちら苦労ベースで字のラインを入れてみました
ちょっと出ている側の弱いんですけどだいたいこんな感じですねちょっと真紅の
クリームゾーン感を出してみました
俺の通じ秒姓です破っすごくいいの大好きなんだこういう方が持つでかっこいいなぁ
次はさてを作っていきましょうあても食べとつけると赤く系ですね赤くロケで攻めよう
かなって思ってるんですけど
できました探偵です
くれていただけないですか微妙な曲線もさんとかいざんねすべきと例えば感染しました
いやっぽいでしょ保育を得たダークナイトかがすごい北赤好きなんでたわけないという
オールこいしょ
まじよくねよしよし何さあまずは兜からいきましょう
あっこ空気車が並ん小崎師のイメージで行こうか2部処ゑぼかぶとを着けていき
ましょう
ああああああ
あえてきました兜でございますやばいだぞいかつくなっちゃったね結構
今中断カーみたいになっちゃったんですけどなんだねちょっとトゲトゲしたのが好きな
んですよねた文房具は
物のかぶってみますとまぁこんな感じですねもうやばい the 完全にヤバイいた
じゃんずっと貼ってよ
全部明け暮れてやつあとちょっとつまんないと思ったんで第二のツムを青にしてみまし
たあの
たぶんこれは良いしないですねどんな鎧をつければによって兜がどう生きるう触ってみ
ます弱いの上を作りましょう夜いう作り方が難しいんだよ
ゼロから作るとめちゃくちゃ時間がかかりそうダンボールをベースにして考えていき
ましょう
ああああああ
大声で完成しました弱いでございます
いや難しかった上がり今ユイカ尽くしすぎるず逆に変だと思ったんでちょっと2位は
チェックに方から何かだしたいんだと思って日本で強い4巻をセットしますか勇者感を
出したかったのでマントをつけてみましたこんな感じです開いてあげるよイラストで
最後は鎧の下星回りの部分を作っ
ていこうと思いますでは行きましょう
おっしゃあできます
アート弱いの様子できました鎧ましたですこんな感じで時なぜの il か迷ったん
ですけどやっぱあの黒だけどちょっとつまんないと思ったんだ
どうせなら入れましたはいというわけで創房景色揃いましたーーー
夜の12時から初めて
今朝の執事ですなかなか近くかかったんですけども満足いくものができたのかなと思い
ます即日に装備してみましょう
エアーんで案ってめっちゃカッ
うんいや何か凄いなもんだから世界の勇者みたいになっちゃってる後は剣と盾を持って
魔王いややぽいでしょなって完全にいる者じゃないですか
ちょっとぐるっと回ってみましょう
あだぜてパーたい方がいい相手技でぼく何とか本気でダンボールでがちな防具を考えて
みましたいかがでしょうかまぁ色々言いたいことがあると思うが
深く追求するがこれが俺の望んだ装備本題はここからです
なーんとなーんとですね今回この木が作った段ボール装備なんとドラゴンクエストで
作ってもらうことになりました
本当にしてくれるのかはいというわけで僕のこのダンボール装備しのドラゴンクエスト
というアプリで実際に作られるみたいでございますめっちゃ切りないんだけどどうなっ
てるんだからこれが装備できますけどね実際にドラッグで動画の説明ながら干場の
ドラゴンクエストダウンロードできますんでよかったらダウンロードしてみてください
そしてこの田治米社長装備
実際に手に入れてみてくださいじゃあ